you're rocker chic yeah you got to get
that denim and rhinestone out exactly
exactly this is like this is tough denim
and rhinestone it is but i'm loving it
and are you just loving all the
celebrating that's going on for denim
and rhinestones
you have been having shows and this
party and that party what has been the
ultimate highlight for this album
release oh golly i mean i feel like
we've been been a lot of places over the
past um few days you know but i mean
it's all good um i've gotten to see some
fans we had our fan club party yeah
tonight i'm gonna see a whole lot of
fans
yes you are just a few tens of thousands
let me deal you know this is a regular
saturday night yeah for you and his
girlfriend for sure um i love it though
i've been listening to the album i'm
really liking burn a lot oh thank you
i love to hear people's favorites
because i feel like they're all they're
they've all been very different people
will like rank you know top to bottom
and you have a particular favorite baby
this time around
not a favorite baby
as far as um
go they are the babies yeah um
i it might depend on the mood um i do
love denim rhinestones i love pink
champagne i love crazy angels i love
garden
um i don't know i don't i don't know you
love them all they do and that is okay
they wouldn't have gone on there if i
didn't love them exactly and i mean
you've accumulated what now 28 number
ones i don't know oh but honey i think
i'm counting i do 28 i do believe can
somebody yeah yeah that's what it is but
they're going to continue to come
give us a little scoop of what's to come
with the tour you just wrapped up vegas
residency incredible are we going to see
more aerial stunts even more
fabulousness of wardrobes do you have a
bus for denim and ride i predict a lot
of denim
a lot of rhinestones uh-huh probably
some fringe yes quaint hair yeah
um
maybe some aerial stuff i i do like to
fly i feel like i've i've done that on
many tours in one way or another i've
been up in the air um sometimes i bring
the band along with me i don't know if
they like that or not
but uh yeah i mean we'll we'll see we're
kind of working out
details now but it'll be it'll be really
good okay this is a preview of what's to
come y'all these boots i can carry you
know what they don't hurt my feet
because i feel like the lift is just
enough for your little self that's good
yeah that is awesome sauce right there
okay so we got a little tease of what's
to come with the tour now something else
you're bringing along on the tour my
friend jimmy allen yes i just love him
to pieces everybody does because he's
got a good soul he's talented he is a
hustler but he was trying to hustle so
hard he was trying to take my job
yes yes i was like really yeah really
carrie what did he do he did it he did
well yeah he did well yeah um and that's
that's a whole different like talent
well you study journalism i did but that
i can i yeah i can write i can read a
teleprompter really well but just
talking to someone and like knowing the
right questions to ask that's a whole
other talent do you like being on the
other end of answering the questions i
like to answer the questions yeah that's
good yeah i always love having a
conversation with you
i also enjoyed seeing uh i don't know if
you saw this circulating around the
internet what did i do
you didn't do anything girl you know
precious boys oh okay i do we're doing
like gosh mad breakdancing that's opera
that was called that was called it's way
past their bedtime
and the little one jake um he was just
trying to
not stop moving because if he did he was
gonna fall asleep so i'm singing a
ballad up there and you also have this
false sense of like
security at the opry when you're back
there you're like kind of back there in
the dark and you feel like nobody can
see you
um so i didn't like i feel like nobody
really thought twice about
them being there and acting crazy
because i don't know and then i saw
videos and i'm like oh and then um
melissa took like video because i had
asked her to take some pictures from
like backstage and she took video of
them doing it and you can see
like isaiah's like looking back and
mike's like i know he's like
get in gear
and then i said he's like why
they get it from their mama i know that
is fortunate they just had to keep
moving future entertainers on your hands
i think so yeah i think so they're not
they're not shy that's for sure no i
that is that is for sure uh lastly
father's day plans that's next sunday i
know you spent mother's day i got i got
freaked out um today i was like
tomorrow's not father's day right
because i haven't done squat we won't
tell you mike i gotta i gotta figure
that out figure out real quick i know my
my son's been doing um
chores around our farm
trying to earn money
so we will pay him for his work he'll go
pull weeds in my garden and stuff like
that and uh he has quite the hefty um
savings he does he does and he'll he
donates some but um i'm gonna be like
you're gonna buy your go daddy he ain't
my daddy
exactly you get him you're gonna earn
that money guess what guess what